unseasonably heavy rains lashed Johor
State last week and the impact is still
being felt
water kept pricing on Monday the River
overflowed its banks and water just kept
coming into the house I made the
decision to leave it was too risky
back to check on his home and belongings
isn't too hopeful there'll be much to
salvage
many others are doing the same
it's bad really bad water up to my knees
how can we go back home there's no way
there's also no way to tell when flood
waters will completely dry out many
people here say this is one of the worst
floods they've experienced far more
severe than the one in 2006. yet there
are some who are still reluctant to
leave their homes even though they've
been advised flood waters could continue
to rise
fire department personnel have been
ferrying people to safety the area is
inundated partly because authorities
recently released water from a nearby
Dam and water levels in rivers are still
high
some people from nearby Villages are
pitching in to help this food truck
organized by a group of friends visits
affected areas to dish out meals to
anyone who needs it
I have helped out during a flood before
so I know how tiring and hungry it can
get especially for Aid workers so now I
try to help it's also out of a sense of
solidarity
volunteers will be needed for the coming
days and weeks a local official has
already said the state will need help
with post-flood cleanup as soon as
Waters recede whenever that may be
Florence Louis Batu pahad Johor State
Malaysia